et la date d'accouchement prévu c'est
bien le 25 mai parce que là il ya un
tableau qui permet de dire quand
l'enfant a été conçu à ok du coup ça
tombe le 7 août
[Musique]
c'est très bon ce sont là c'est quoi
c'est à minima très très bon et ben je
serai avec vous ce soir c'est soirée
folle envolée à lutter je me suis bien
là c'est beau merci les mecs si tu veux
chope et intéressant tire donc qu'il
faille à la baule ou pas pour moi genre
de fait
mais que tu vas pas rester enfermé dans
cette coupe david à mais je crois pas
l'intérêt de courir là comme un coach je
sais pas
déjà qu'on n'est pas douloureux l'a
alors si personne ne bouge
le dernier l'éjaculât pas dans cinq
minutes donc la mini aux gens ce qu'ils
m'ont plage tu regardes un merci
[Musique]
attendez ah oui c'était le pacs pacte
euro non mais je savais que vous allez
monsieur mais ça peut être aussi beaux
les gars se fait pas non mais pourquoi
je voudrais de vous orienter dans la
décision même je suis fait qu un premier
verdict en situation de l'eau disponible
ici
[Musique]
ces bus
vous
[Musique]
enfin non
alors c'est moi c'est ok bon on y
retourne non mais basé sur moi ils ne
laissent pas rentrer à merde pourquoi
ouais choix des façons
chacun loser but jamais rien de ma vie
autant crever direct ah ben non mais
pourquoi tu dis ça mais on va faire des
grandes choses tous les mois vincent
devrait pas y penser
maintenant oui
ah mais moi mais t'inquiète pas je
connais physio c'est un ancien barman du
[ __ ] univers sympa vas-y bien où il va
bon cela tombe mal et ça va saigner
c'est bien le conduire à cibler on peut
rentrer oui cent pages avec m
d accord
je l'amour un ouais tu aurais pu revenir
donc moi non plus on a mieux sur ce
devait être trop bien non bah oui
[Musique]